[Musique]
tout commence à la nuit des temps quand
les hommes adorent les dieux
êtres surnaturels qu'ils appellent
divinités mentionnées par les inscripteurs sumériens
des centaines de ces divinités à quelques minutes de
ciel il y a 400 mille ans pour s'installer
dans une Mésopotamie d'aspect humanoïde
technologiquement très avancé mais
répartis en deux catégories, l'une supérieure
et l'autre plus bas
ces êtres appelés anunnaki si
ils poursuivent et ils font la guerre oui
épouser des frères et sœurs avoir des dieux
les enfants sont mortels et la durée de la
leur durée de vie correspond à des milliers d'années
terrestres les plus importants d'entre eux sont
le roi hano et ses fils el dans les listes
les anunnaki cherchent de l'or pour
nébulisant dans l'atmosphère pour eux
planète nibiru pour former une couche
qui le réchauffe, ils le trouvent dans
abondance en afrique au zimbabwe mais
leur troupe composée d'astronautes
catégorie inférieure
il refuse bientôt de creuser la terre
[Musique]
enki convainquit alors le chef du
mission que l'amélioration d'un primate
homo erectus africain le problème de
la main-d'œuvre sera résolue ainsi 300 mille
il y a des années, la moissonneuse-batteuse anunnaki
génétiquement leur ADN avec l'ADN de
une femelle directe et après divers
tentatives cela engendre le premier homme
l'homme sapiens
est un mâle créé à l'image d'un
ne sait pas qui est apte à comprendre les ordres
et creuser dans les mines d'or
anunnaki crowe nano i sapiens est dans
grande quantité et de les nourrir
ils construisent l'eden un terrain clôturé
où ils manipulent l'épeautre sauvage
en faire du blé et où il change
génétiquement certains animaux sauvages
pour les rendre domestiques ou comestibles je
plus chanceux sapiens appelé à des amis
ils sont génétiquement améliorés et apportés
en eden pour travailler comme fermiers
et éleveurs alors que de simples sapiens
apportés aux mines d'or sont
forcé de creuser à mort pour
puis être donné aux animaux
étant des hybrides, les sapiens sont
stérile et cela oblige les médecins
annonce tout le temps de les cloner mais
pas assez d'emplois pour
long
les dirigeants Anunnaki décident alors de
rendre l'homme fertile et avec les siens
les cellules souches produisent la femme
cependant pour empêcher le sapiens et
devenir dangereux et réduire
génétiquement les gènes de leurs ongles e
de leurs dents
en même temps ils développent les gènes de la
leurs cheveux pour qu'ils poussent
continuation
cela complique la survie dans
la nature mais les cheveux des femmes excitent
les Anunnaki de grade inférieur que
ils en abusent en trouvant un exutoire
sexuel
encore aujourd'hui pour ne pas provoquer
désir des dieux religions
ils obligent les femmes à se couvrir la tête
[Musique]
en fait les sapiens adorent les
anunnaki les prenant pour des dieux et non
ne les voyant jamais mourir, ils croient
immortel mais cette idée se comporte de
bergers imposant leurs ordres
à force de coups donc sous le
la menace des châtiments divins y est née
la religion un système très obéissant
efficace qui dure jusqu'à aujourd'hui
[Musique]
aucun avec lequel ils ont un problème cependant
l'air terrestre préférant vivre sur
sommets des montagnes où l'air est plus
raréfiés ils calment leur étouffement
inhaler les endorphines contenues dans la fumée
de la graisse brûlée mais conscient que c'est
difficile de les atteindre en montagne
ils construisent des pyramides où
les hommes doivent monter pour les rencontrer e
prendre des ordres
avec le temps les hommes se multiplient
excessivement et cela inquiète
le chef de mission terre et lille
et n'aime pas les humains craint les leurs
l'intelligence surtout celle de
aux amis et quand ils sont intéressés
trop à la technologie les anunnaki
chassé d'eden l n'avertit pas les humains
pas même du déluge imminent quittant
laissez-les tous se noyer
les seuls à être sauvés sont les Anunnaki
regarder leur désastre
vaisseaux spatiaux
mais el frère en qui apprécie
les humains et me prévient lazio du sud
ra le nom biblique de la construction
une arche pour sauver sa famille et
le patrimoine génétique des animaux e
des plantes créées pour leven
[Musique]
quand le déluge se termine il ne reste plus que ceux
certains humains ont fui vers les montagnes et les
famille de fermeture qui s'unissent
en repeuplant la terre après la
inonder les anunnaki décident de
diviser les terres émergées
ainsi les premières nations naissent chacune
dirigé par une grand-mère dont les gens
est formé par les humains survivants qui
ils ont atteint ces terres
[Musique]
cependant, les anunnaki ont besoin de leaders
personnes vers qui se tourner pour leur donner
commandes puis rejoignez les femmes plus
beaux et ceux-ci génèrent la colère des héros du
mortels dotés d'un pouvoir supérieur
anti né des dirigeants actuels de
ce monde
[Musique]
un de ces gilgamesh devient célèbre
pour laquelle il aspire à l'immortalité
mais cela n'est possible que sur nibiru
la planète des pubs où les
mouvement autour du soleil des autres
paramètres de temps
pour le partage de la terre
qui décide des missions murdoch
puissant fils d'enki et déçu car
il ne reçoit que la Mésopotamie centrale
celui qui aspire à un empire
après avoir fondé la première Babylone
l'arme de ses hommes était à bord de son
machine à détruire les conduit au
nid
[Musique]
les anciens textes égyptiens mentionnent ces
des géants aux pouvoirs surnaturels
[Musique]
les plus importants sont appelés marduk
maintenant dieu soleil son fils top dieu de
connaître et utiliser le dieu de la bagarre des âmes
assassiné par son frère 7
le dieu du mal
[Musique]
quand marduk et entre en egypte savent bien
auquel ce territoire est attribué
née vierge fille préférée du royaume
malatacca directement dans les pyramides
construit par les rois et robbie
de ce conflit et profiter de la
grand-mère qui est à qui a été attribué le
soudan envahir l'egypte repoussant
marduk à babylone et né en grèce mais
la Grèce a déjà été assignée à
frère du royaume le dieu irascible
Poséidon et cela ne veut pas d'intrus
était aussi son petit-fils né en faveur de
né plus tard appelé athena dai
Les Grecs
le même réalise le bio
haut égyptien appelé hermès par les grecs et
le dieu de l'atoll de sparte athena si
puis s'installe dans la plaine Attique
où il a fondé Athènes
mais il doit immédiatement la protéger de
peuples de la mer et des attaques du dieu
le royaume appelé lui suffit
Zeus des Grecs ne peut que recommencer
quand nibiru s'approche du
Terre
en attendant il s'installe sur le mont olympe
non loin de sa fille Athéna e
profitez des beautés de la grèce
surtout des femmes grecques
Zeus est aussi un juge sévère quand
promet ou vole la connaissance du vin pour
donner aux hommes
zeus et punit sévèrement et le punit
voire toute l'humanité
via pandora pandora est magnifique
ouvre le bocal qui contient les maux de
monde et ceux-ci se répandent partout
condamner l'humanité à
souffrance pas encore satisfaite zeus
provoque une inondation qui noie tout
êtres vivants à l'exception d'un homme e
d'une femme qui peuple le monde
Homer et Desio mentionnent ces dieux de
il a la peau et les os laiteux et vit dessus
Mont Olympe et ordonnez des sacrifices
animaux pour inhaler la fumée de la graisse
brûlé
[Musique]
la division du monde continue dans
le sud de la Mésopotamie attribué à lo
im e cha dai l'héroïne est le nom par lequel
Les Juifs appellent un qui dans ce
la grande famille des
Abraham sumérien qu'il divise d'alors
parmi leurs enfants qu'amos milkon et ave
[Musique]
j'appelle sam oreille avec les familles de réception
des deux frères d'Abraham tandis que le
adv et reçoit la famille des descendants
d'abraham des Sumériens appelé j'aurais le
dont le chef Jacob est décrit comme un
un rusé
[Musique]
les hubs et est un jeune militaire qui
aspire à étendre les territoires de
santé sa femme à cirer le nourrit
Juifs avec de grandes quantités de pain et lui
s'entraîner pour la guerre quand ils sont prêts
avoir cobbe ordinaire qui renomme
Israël massacre de familles
voisin
à commencer par les femmes et les enfants
[Musique]
le feuillage ne plaisante pas comme les autres
anunnaki se saoule avec le shakhtar si
se calmer en inhalant la fumée de la graisse
brûlé d'un nouveau-né et tue n'importe qui
lui désobéir soutenu par murdoch
key bombarde les villes frontalières de
Sodome et Gomorrhe et refusent de
trahir leurs élohim et zébu et del
fagor les adversaires directs de key qui
depuis lors, ils seront appelés des démons
belzébuth et belfagor
le hub est celui que marduk recommande
diversifier génétiquement la langue
des bâtisseurs de la tour de babel
ces bâtisseurs sont des hommes
ingénieux et après avoir copié les techniques
les vaisseaux spatiaux anunnaki ont construit
missile caché à l'intérieur de la tour
avec ce missile, ils espèrent
atteindre nibiru où la vie dure
les milliers d'années où les Babyloniens
remplacer les Sumériens de ce peuple
il ne reste que la famille de Jacob et
elle l'avait fait bouger en lui promettant
eux le pays de canaan bien qu'après
l'épisode de sodome et gomorrhe
craignant pour sa propre sécurité
Haven n'utilise plus ses armes
les détruire en me laissant les avoir
combattre seul de ce ne
les puissants voisins du
Juifs surtout les Égyptiens qui les ont trouvés
ils asservissent souvent
puis l'abeille intervient en organisant
la fuite des juifs d'egypte
conseille à Moïse de voler les richesses
du pharaon et d'utiliser ce
butin à payer des mercenaires qui
laissez-les former une génération dans le désert
de guerriers juifs puis de Moïse un
des centaines de commandes de sorte que si le
se dépêcher seul sans le déranger en vain
fort de cette armée les Juifs
ils massacrent les peuples qu'ils rencontrent sur
ils passent et arrivent dans le pays de
canaan où ils ont fondé israël s'ils voulaient
imiter les Grecs devenus prestigieux
grâce aux livres d'Homère le juif
ils décident alors d'écrire l'histoire
de leur pacte avec des normes clés et la
leurs aventures pour atteindre la terre
promesse de le faire sont inspirés par les paroles
écrit par les Sumériens deux mille ans plus tôt
citant ainsi les dieux qu'ils créent
homme qui possède des armes destructrices e
qui se calment en inhalant la graisse
animal brûlé
[Musique]
tous ces textes la bible
L'hébreu mentionne également dans mais le haut de la
messagers divins identiques à l'homme e
dangereux pour les femmes aux cheveux
long
[Musique]
dans la division du monde
la vallée de l'Indus est assignée au sommeil
dans hannah son passé est beau dans
mésopotamie marisa déesse de l'amour
quand à anna il s'agit de la rivière Indo
inactif l'appellent les étoiles et le
ils adorent avec ses compagnons
géants marchant à la mode
insolite laissant des empreintes étranges
sur la vue au sol renvoie le
matriarcat et dans la vallée de l'Indus où
la vie continue paisiblement
la pensée des hommes tournée vers
réflexion sur quelques territoires européens
sont attribués au prince charmant
rama a une fois son peuple arrivé
composée de Mésopotamiens n'apprécie pas la
température froide
puis à Rome il partit avec sa cour
des dieux et des humains parcourant le monde
à la recherche d'un territoire où
régner
quand ils arrivent en Inde mon désir
large attribution de l'Inde du Nord non
s'oppose à rama rebaptisé bis b oui
puis s'installe en fondant la culture
Indo-européen dont la langue est le sanskrit
un mélange de langues européennes héritées de
ceux qui l'ont suivi en sanskrit
qui sont écrits je vois un ensemble de
textes scientifiques qui mentionnent des dieux
vaisseaux spatiaux appelés vimana delle
armes énergétiques de batailles insensées e
du bombardement des villes
l'arrivée de lama irrite le dieu de
destruction shiva sud cessionnaire
L'Inde qui s'y oppose au départ mais
puis forcé à un accord
les trois dieux forment alors la trimurti
Hindouisme mais une nuit les guerriers
les noirs de shiva attaquent en force et les
Indo-Européens et chassez-les
de l'inde aussi bien que d'habitude
s'impose à lui, les hommes sont tous
des dieux mais lorsqu'ils abusent des
leur divinité aspire les châtie
cachant leur pouvoir divin
où ils ne le trouveront jamais dans le leur
en moi
alors les hommes explorent la terre je
mers et le ciel sans jamais atteindre le
divinité qui a donc en eux
[Musique]
pendant ce temps rama et les indo-européens
ils traversent des déserts et des montagnes et
ils arrivent au moyen-orient où ils sont bien
accueilli par le cessionnaire d'Anatolie
le dieu créateur et l'intrigue en colère oui
installe son frère sur le mont Argea
viracocha en décide autrement suivi de
son fidèle viracocha traverse l'Asie
passe le détroit de Béring longe le
paisible et arrive sur la chaîne de montagnes
des andes où l'air est bon pour
les anunnaki les natifs des montagnes
Les andins vénèrent les nouveaux arrivants
les faisant parce que les dieux appellent
viracocha tonato le dieu soleil
le représentant ainsi que son entourage
comme les astronautes qu'ils utilisent
commande des leviers faisant voler des véhicules qui
probablement atterrir et décoller
sur les premières pentes de nasca
[Musique]
Les écritures boliviennes mentionnent la déesse
pachamama grande mère de la terre qui a
à bord de son vaisseau spatial à terre à
le lac de titicaca génère 70 enfants e
recommence dans le ciel
[Musique]
des voitures brillantes qui descendent
du ciel ils arrivent sur le malaja où le
et les écritures tibétaines décrivent les pilotes
comme des dieux volants
d'autres voitures volantes atterrissent
japon empereur jimbo un dieu doué
d'un miroir magique un écran qui
lui permet d'observer les îles des
Pacifique
jimbo fonde le shinto une religion
polythéiste qui prêche l'harmonie e
hygiène corporelle
[Musique]
dans la Chine voisine à cette époque
les hommes s'habillent en peaux oui
ils se nourrissent comme des animaux et un sans
règles et sans morale une légende
dit qu'en découvrant un jour
l'empreinte d'un géant une fille
repose sur son pied et général dio
le héros foxy et sa soeur la déesse nua sont
représenté avec le corps d'un être
humain formé par deux serpents que vous
entrelacés les uns avec les autres comme des doubles
hélices d'adn fuchsia un dieu éducateur
enseigne la civilisation invente l'écriture
Formules chinoises aux règles morales et un
à bord de sa machine volante
ressemblant à une tortue court le long de la
la chine soutient l'union des tribus
Chinois sous le symbole du dragon
mais il avait seize ans et sa soeur n'est pas seule
cessionnaires de la chine
le dieu de appelé l'empereur jaune
il soumet les groupes ethniques qu'ils occupent dans le nord
de Chine
et qui connaît sa capitale à Pékin
[Musique]
dieu jan di appelé l'empereur rouge
occupe le nord-ouest de la Chine tandis que
cils le dieu et les coréens sont limités à
contenir ses voisins guerriers
la littérature chinoise ancienne décrit
ces dieux comme des guerriers géants
qui se disputent entre eux qui se marient entre
frères et sœurs et se calmer
inhaler la fumée de la graisse environnante
les intestins des brûlés
[Musique]
d'autres voitures volantes arrivent en australie
où les aborigènes les appellent je
frères de foudre les représentant
comme des astronautes
[Musique]
en Scandinavie, les ayants droit sont
les haches des divinités géantes vénérées
par les Hyperboréens et ancêtres des Vikings
à la fin de la glaciation du Biasi ont
a quitté les branches de la cour en Anatolie pour
s'installer dans leurs possessions du nord
Les Européens détestent leur dieu principal de
la connaissance et la guerre est suivie par son
fils torre le plus fort des dieux et
autres divinités nordiques
d'autres des géants du
corte di rama retour en europe après
le dégel sont les tuathas de d'anna
fondateurs de la culture celtique
re il est le dieu suprême suivi de la déesse
mère brigitte du dieu du tonnerre Taranis
du dieu des druides au ciel du dieu
de l'actualité de la maison magique et autres
[Musique]
au dix-septième siècle avant Jésus-Christ de nouveaux systèmes
de la pensée apparaissent simultanément
remplacer la religion par
la philosophie au népal bouddha sens que
l'homme est un esprit éternel qui vit
différentes étapes du jaïnisme indien
il croit aussi à la réincarnation
de l'illumination en chine laos e
annonce que tau et balance
parfait supportant l'univers mais un
son contemporain Confucius refuse de
croire aux arguments surnaturels dans
la grèce aussi socrate aristote et di
sûr qu'ils rejettent le surnaturel
expliquer le monde par l'action des lois
Naturel
[Musique]
cela n'empêche pas Athéna de devenir
la déesse grecque de la guerre pour dominer
milite sur la mer Egée mais les conflits
continu entre dix et sparte s'affaiblir
la grèce qui a alors envahi par
alexandre le grand et plus tard par les romains
[Musique]
à cette époque les hommes sont
multiplié de manière disproportionnée e
difficile de les contrôler et les anunnaki
bien qu'équipé d'armes mortelles non
est-ce une centaine
alors il suffit de comprendre la situation et oui
s'adapte préférant le caractère guerrier
des Romains à la philosophie grecque déplacer i
propres intérêts vis-à-vis des entreprises prometteuses
rome nouveau centre du pouvoir
[Musique]
athéna puis appelée minerva dai
romains zeus devient jupiter poséidon
ça devient Neptune et ainsi de suite
[Musique]
aussi la littérature romaine antique
décrit ces dieux comme des géants
belliqueux et calmez-vous en inhalant la fumée
de graisse animale brûlée
rome fort du soutien de minerve
domine les nations qui entourent le
méditerranée y compris israël ce
cela l'effraye de n'avoir de lui que des Juifs qui
ordonne alors à l'archange gabriel di
intervenir et génétiquement sur
vierge marie pour qu'elle conçoive
un homme supérieur joshua jesus s'appelle
jésus combinant les noms Josué et Zeus
faire ressortir le caractère du vin
doit remplir une mission précise
chasser les romains d'israël
[Musique]
Mais la rébellion juive a échoué et Jésus
et crucifié par les Romains
[Musique]
cependant les rebelles l'enlèvent toujours
Je vis de la croix et je la porte sur un
vaisseau spatial l'historien juif
giuseppe flavio écrit que quand je
les romains détruisent jérusalem comme
les divinités répondent à cette rébellion
ils s'enfuient à bord de grands chars célestes
aussi l'historien romain da cito affirme
qu'il y avait des batailles dans le ciel
depuis lors les romains ont fortifié les leurs
occupation et la clé disparaît
de Palestine
[Musique]
quelques décennies plus tard, un Juif
romano paolo di tarsus l'inspirateur du
la religion chrétienne déclare que Jésus est
un dieu fils de dieu mais en forme
l'homme est apparu sur terre pour libérer
hommes du péché originel mais le
la bible hébraïque ne parle d'aucun
péché et blasphématoire pour les Juifs
affirmer qu'un homme est un Paul Dieu
puis falsifie la bible hébraïque
lui faisant prophétiser la venue de Jésus
s'inspire d'histoires mystiques tirées de
littérature indienne ancienne à extraire
les Evangiles sont l'ensemble de ces textes
compose la bible chrétienne
[Musique]
son message est bien reçu par
Romains polythéistes qui se convertissent à
Christianisme mais peu de temps après
ce sont les chrétiens eux-mêmes qui sont divisés
se heurtant à la divinité de Jésus
ces contrastes sont réduits au silence 315
quand le concile de nicée déclare
celui qui nie que Jésus soit dieu est un hérétique
fils de Dieu
[Musique]
l'empereur romain et a ensuite déclaré
pontife de la religion chrétienne
réunissant l'État et la religion sous
un pouvoir
[Musique]
depuis lors l'église catholique de rome
héritier du christianisme de Paul
cache la bible hébraïque originale
pour que personne ne sache que c'est une copie
contrefaçon dans les écrits sur simple je
qui ne parlent pas de dieu ou de dieux
des êtres spirituels mais pas guerriers
humains dans le reste du monde
les autres religions font la même chose
leurs livres sacrés sont des copies
écrits contrefaits sur meri con
le paradoxe que tout en définissant le
leurs contrefaçons comme vraies qu'ils jugent
fassi les originaux à partir desquels ils ont
copié
mais comment les anciens pouvaient-ils
écrire dans le monde entier
inventer des êtres et des faits comme ça
tous semblables les uns aux autres
dans la même période historique entre
milliards de planètes et impensable que le
la vie n'est apparue que sur terre est
il est donc possible que des êtres d'autrui
les planètes viennent à nous
pour la même raison, il pousse aussi
à nous aventurer dans l'espace
[Musique]
ce n'est peut-être pas un être surnaturel
cet archange gabriel qui semble
Mohammed en Arabie cet archange déjà
mentionné dans la bible comme malachin qui
apparu à la vierge marie est un militaire
haute hiérarchie porteur d'ordres
degli elohim gabriele transmet à
Mohammed la parole du dieu allah et la
transcription de ces mots
constitue le Coran le livre saint des dieux
Mohammed Muslims se présente au
Les juifs comme prophète dernier et définitif
mais ils se moquent de lui puis de l'arme de Mohammed
ses fidèles combattent les Juifs e
changer la direction de la prière de
Jérusalem à La Mecque
[Musique]
prophète et chef militaire Mohammed fonds marins
critiquer le monothéisme fondamentaliste
pour lequel tu n'as pas besoin de croire
constater l'existence d'allah
le seul dieu créateur
[Musique]
la dernière religion dans l'ordre chronologique
qui reconnaît un dieu créateur unique
apparaît en inde où le gourou nanak fonde
Le sikhisme est une religion qui prêche la
gentillesse et prière
bien
mais en europe où l'éducation est là
la science progresse rapidement
la religion est remise en cause par
La Révolution française et le mouvement
des Lumières
l'idée que les théologiens peuvent affirmer
ce qu'ils veulent sans le prouver
totalement impensable pour
scientifiques et doit toujours prouver
quelle est l'histoire de la
religions
alors ça devient une discipline
la science et les gouvernements occidentaux font
ils libèrent du clergé en devenant laïcs
pourtant le besoin de foi de l'humanité
persiste et s'adapte aux temps
remplaçant le dieu surnaturel un
dieu concret ce nouveau dieu et le
l'argent et sa religion prêche
richesse obtenue grâce à la dette
[Musique]
belliqueux le dieu de l'argent déclare le
la guerre sainte
Christianisme à l'Islam et tout ça
qui n'est pas à vendre
comme les moyeux, c'est aussi l'arme du dieu de l'argent
mercenaires sans foi ni patrie
les faisant massacrer des millions de
innocent au nom du marché et acheter
tant et si bien qu'au lieu de s'unir contre
fondamentalisme économique
les religions assimilent le nouveau culte
accélérant sa propre disparition
[Musique]
mais l'histoire n'est pas finie car le dieu
l'argent engendre plus d'enfants
le dernier est tech le dieu de la technologie
ses prêtres sont un petit groupe de
jeunes milliardaires installés dans le
Silicon Valley dont l'ambition est que
soumettre le monde en le contrôlant
avec l'informatique, c'est qu'il adorait
surtout par les jeunes mais son
la religion prêche l'intelligence
artificiel
imprimantes 3d et réalité virtuelle
réduire le nombre d'emplois e
poussant des millions de misère
ouvriers
[Applaudissements]
de leur côté, les milliardaires du silicium
la vallée n'a aucun scrupule et oui
s'enrichir de plus en plus en vendant
superflu
[Musique]
tout comme le catholicisme c'est
enrichi en pillant le monde e
vente d'images sacrées illusoires
[Musique]
tout comme l'Islam et devient riche
grâce au pétrole
donc tu ne veux pas de planète et avec ça
argent armes terrorisme
tout comme l'hindouisme qui me divise
posséder des fidèles en castes et les laisser mourir
les plus pauvres de la faim et tout comme
Judaïsme et depuis l'époque de Jacob e
sprock et toujours leurs propres voisins à coups
de canon
[Musique]
et l'histoire de notre passé mais aussi
de notre présent
ce qu'on vous a dit est aussi
l'histoire des religions et que les dieux
existent ou non et leur nom qui
naïf massacrer les autres naïfs
croire qu'il est juste de le faire
[Musique]
un jour peut-être la rationalité triomphera
sur cette ignorance bien appréciée
des religions
[Musique]
alors nous deviendrons tous si évolués à partir de
pouvoir jouer et faire l'amour
des jours comme au bon vieux temps où
nous étions encore très simples
singes
[Musique]